CASSIE KOZYRKOV: With almost
500 sessions at Next 2019,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see AI Hub,
The One Place for Everything AI,
then stay tuned, because
here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The AI universe is
expanding, which
means you can get more creative
with it than ever before,
and the possibilities
are endless.
Unfortunately, it might
feel like the things
you need to learn to get
going are endless too.
The space has grown huge,
messy, and daunting.
So what if you could step
into a tight, parallel AI
universe that
combines everything
you need to make your experience
with building AI magical?
Welcome to AI Hub.
The vision behind
Google Cloud's AI Hub
is to give you a
10x force multiplier
by taking the
confusion, repetition,
and wheel reinvention
right out of your work.
AI Hub brings together a
number of managed services
to make your lives easier.
And because AI is a
team sport, AI Hub
is designed with skills
diversity in mind
and focuses on making it
easy to do what you do best
and then share your
work with colleagues
who love the other parts.
It's for the data scientist who
wants to work on the cutting
edge without the painful
slow going every time you
want to try something new.
It's for the app
developer looking
for that familiar
pattern of discovery
without getting dunked in the
mathematical nitty gritty.
And it's for the machine
learning production engineer
who keeps getting asked
why the model took
three weeks to build but 10
months to put into production.
Hint-- production
used to be hard.
It's for the person who loves
point and click in a great UI
and for the person who likes
direct command line access.
Whoever you are, if you
build with AI, it's for you.
AI Hub isn't just a ski lift for
your machine learning chores.
It's the whole resort.
And as a result, the talk is
quite frankly unsummarizable.
It is just too dense
with incredible demos,
and you'll definitely
want to experience them.
But here is a small taste.
AI Hub features instant
VM and Jupyter Notebook
setup, a brain-friendly,
brilliantly
searchable repository
of code to get
you started, collaboration
tools, extra transfer learning
support, and Kubeflow
Fairing to jumpstart
your move to production
with ready-to-go, end-to-end
pipeline templates and
broken-down components
to help you mix
and match instead
of reinventing that wheel.
Oh, and don't forget
access to TFX.
That's TensorFlow
Extended, Google's recently
open-sourced, tailor-made
production machine learning
pipeline with advanced
model analytics capabilities
that accelerate your
development process,
helping you iterate
in a smarter direction
to launch your
awesome system faster.
This is the power
to build quickly.
It's the joy of
collaborating without having
to take everything on
your own shoulders,
and it's the beauty of
enjoying a magical user
experience as an AI builder.
If you'd like to
see the full talk,
check out the link in
the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more great
Next Rewind content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]